uh thanks guys uh first since I have
this page want to say thank you to
organizers of this week and the
whole of this week and the whole okay
that seems better I want to say thank
you to this for for the organizers of
this week and the whole semester for a
wonderful
program okay so uh the title of my talk
is um quo quotient sparsification for
some modular functions and I think in
the time allotted my goal is just to
roughly explain each of the terms uh in
the title so I'll start with stuff we're
used to um so graphs uh you know two
cuts and graphs right so I give you some
unweighted graph uh maybe a dense graph
uh with some Edge weights right and uh
and as we know
sorry uh a cut is just uh you know put
some vertices on one side put some
vertices on the other the edges going
across the two sets that's that's a cut
everyone of course knows
this um right here would be another uh
picture of a cut I really went all out
on these pictures um this would be uh
another cut you know edges that are
between
vertices don't
count on the same
side okay so so cut values are important
as have been kind of reinforced all
semester uh you know they determine the
max flow or connectivity or you know we
hear about expanders all the time right
these are all fun of
cuts okay
so in in Cut sparsification
uh you know we're given some kind of
input graph and and this is particularly
useful when the graph is maybe very
dense and maybe there's some redundant
uh
information and the high level idea is
to somehow produce some kind of sparer
graph right same vertex set fewer edges
you're allowed to reweight the edge
weights uh and and we really want number
of edges to be small we want to compress
things we want the the ensuing algorithm
to run faster on a smaller input set and
in the case of in the case of cut
sparsification
uh I want to preserve the weight of
every cut so if I drop some edges I'll
necessarily have to increase the weight
of some other edges to
compensate and so uh you know a very
important uh result in this area
following a line of of results uh and
carer uh showed that you know you can
start with something close to N squ
edges but you can get it down to n log n
over Epsilon
s uh and guarantee that for any of these
Cuts I'll preserve the weight of the cut
up to a one plus Epsilon Factor okay so
maybe 10% error or something like this
for every
cut right so it's just quite uh
surprising um and now we understand this
phenomenon much better we have you know
spectral sparsifiers we can actually get
rid of the login which is spectacular um
there's lots of other perspectives on
these Cuts we kind of heard one
implicitly this morning as
well okay so uh of recent interest has
been uh generalizing this kind of
framework to hypergraphs so this is my
best attempt to draw a hypergraph it
remains open to draw a pleasant
hypergraph um uh but you know the only
difference from
before uh was a regular graph is that a
hyper Edge can have more than two
vertices so here if you can barely make
out the colors everything's a triangle
having three vertices uh in each
Edge okay and uh otherwise the
definition is the same I take a set of
vertices on one side and I'm looking at
the edges that go
across the cut just inside one side that
doesn't count right here's uh another
another example right um another example
yeah so okay so so these are I guess
cuts of some kind of
hypergraph so hypergraph Cuts
spcification we can frame roughly the
same problem as before I give you a a
really dense uh hyper graph and uh and I
want to come up with some subgraph you
know only retain a subset of the edges
uh and I'm allowed to again adjust the
edge weights and just like before
morally I I want to keep the number of
edges I retain small small as
possible uh and I want to preserve the
weight of every two cut in
the okay and so this has been some
recent interest and there's been a
number of results um but a very strong
one by Chen kagda uh was sort of able to
uh recover uh the cargo result which is
they can get the number of hyper is down
to n log n Epsilon
s uh while preserving uh the weight of
every two cut up to 1 plus
Epsilon and uh there are other results
in this space often incomparable uh or
more general or something like this so
there's been sort of spectral analog
sort of inspired by the spectral line of
work um you can also uh sparsify sums of
symmetric of modular functions which
also generalizes this um
any okay
so okay so so what I want to present
today is is some generalization of this
hypergraph cut spif fire and really just
a certain uh combinatorial
perspective so I have to unfortunately
introduce quite a lot of
definitions uh but let me start with
with Metroid so so Metroid is sort of a
combinatorial set system this is what we
call the ground set just some set of
elements okay and and and script I is
the family of feasible sets also called
the the independent
sets and we have uh just three basic
governing
rules one is that the empty set always
counts as
feasible the second is uh the hereditary
property so if I have two sets S and
T and T is feasible and S is a subset T
then s is also feasible and lastly maybe
most interestingly if you have two
feasible sets any two feasible sets but
one is bigger than the other so T is
bigger than S in cardinality you can
always find an
element in t but not s that you can add
to S and maintain feasibility this
augmentation or exchange property
sometimes
called okay so uh these last two
properties actually tell you that a
maximal independent set like I just keep
trying to add elements or maintaining
feasibility will always be
maximum okay so as many of you know like
greedy algorithms tend to be very well
behaved in this stuff because of this so
okay let's do uh an example that we're
all very familiar with the graphic
Metroid so these are Forest so all right
fix some some graph some underlying
graph and the ground set sort of our
elements will be the edges so every
element is an edge Edge not a vertex and
the feasible sets are any Edge set
that's a cylic or a forest in the gra
right so just to check off these
properties as we get warmed up an empty
Edge set counts as a forest not a very
interesting Force but still a
forest uh a subset of a forest is a
forest and as you guys know uh if you
have two Forest but uh one has strictly
more edges than another then uh the the
larger Forest I should be able to find
some Edge and connect two different
components of the smaller
forest and
maintain okay so that's this we all know
we all know that Min spanning tree has n
minus one edes and stuff like this
okay all right I have a few more
terminologies okay um all right so let
me let me explain this notion of of rank
so the rank of a set s is in general the
maximum cardinality of any independent
set
so give me a bunch of forest and say oh
what's the size of the spanning forest
of and we sometimes refer to the rank of
a Metroid as the the rank of just
everything so for the graphic Metroid um
you know if I have some set of edges
s uh we'll just you know get the
maximum Forest so I'm just going to take
as many edges as possible without
inducing a cycle and uh if we kind of
just think it through this is actually
going to be n minus number of connected
components okay so if it's a connected
graph uh the maximum cardinality is n
minus one which again just reinforcing
what you
know I want to point out three
properties about uh rank because rank is
actually just going to be a specific
example of something we could work with
so when it's
monotone if I take more elements I might
be able to make the maximum cality
independent set
bigger the second and very important is
sub
modularity so if I have two sets s and t
okay and I consider like uh adding The
Element e to S and I evaluate it right
which for rank is saying oh am I going
to be able to increase the cardinality
of a maximum independent
Set uh if s is smaller than T then then
sort of that gain relative to S will
always be at least the gain relative to
T because e might be redundant for T but
not necessarily
redundant increasing marginal returns
last point is a little bit uh more
technical but to make the bounds work
it's normalized in the sense that any
marginal value you know I'm adding e to
T and evaluating it it's either zero or
at least one right I'm either adding an
element to my my base or I'm
not so if you didn't have this property
you'd have to rescale
okay another terminology to
span so for a fixed set s the span of a
set s uh the span is going to be the set
of elements that don't increase the the
value uh and and a set is closed if it's
equal to its own
span so so for the graphic Metroid I
have some set ofes s okay and the span
is going to be all the edges that are
already connected my set so this will
not help me increase the size of a four
is the
maximum making progress we finally got
to one term from the
title okay so a
quotient a quotient is a
compl uh of a close set so Q's a quoti
if I look at the complement as closed or
or I can say oh I I look at uh the span
of some set that's automatically closed
what's everything else that's not
spanned by S that's
a um that was terminology that I I
picked up in a paper by
carer so for a graphic Metroid uh and I
have some set of edges S as we saw the
span is the edges that are already
connected so if I remove all those edges
or I look outside what's left is the the
edges going
across
components so a quotient is some kind of
Metroid language to express a cut in the
language we're used
to okay so
um all right Metroid quotient
sparsification what does that mean okay
I give you some some Metroid uh where n
is the number of elements and R is the
rank of the Metroid I don't know how to
draw a general metri I just stuck with a
a graph um and the goal is is uh you
know just trying to pattern match after
graphs trying to reduce the number of
elements but trying to preserve the
weight of every quotient which we saw it
generalizes a
cut okay so so okay so for this then uh
this is what we're able to
get uh we're able to get you know the
number of elements I take or the P of
the weight however you want to look at
it is going to be proportional to the
rank of the Metroid log n Epsilon
s okay and uh and it's going to preserve
the weight of every quotient up to this
error parameter so if you want 10% error
this will become 100 times our
login okay um and you can do it fast and
things like this that's okay all right
um I want to uh take this and just
project it back onto the stuff we're
used to so let's look again at the the
graphic Metroid where again the
independent sets are
Forest so again you know they have this
span and and the quotients are are the
edges being cut right so preserving
quotients or preserving cuts and I just
want to plug in these parameters so for
this R log n where R is the
rank uh that will map to n log n in the
graph where n is the number of vertices
so sorry a mixup of notation but if if
uh as we're kind of used to in graph
language N is a number of vertices that
gives the rank of the metric really n
minus one is the rank of the graphic so
you'll get n log n over Epsilon squ
edges like we were hoping and
expecting um and then this is saying
again we approximate all the cuts so it
matches uh the bang CH carer
guarantee okay so I want to try to
generalize this a little bit more okay
and I'll give an example
as
well so uh we talked about
uh you know the rank function had these
three properties before it was monotone
submodular and normalized okay and for
general f not just rank functions we can
have the same Notions as before I can
Define like the span of a set as the
elements that don't increase the March
the the
value uh I can have Clos sets if it's
equal to its own span and a a quotient
is the complement of a closed set okay
so we just take rank we plug in F same
definitions um and then the rank of this
function will be the the overall value
of the whole thing F of the
gra okay so for hyper graphs we can look
at this function f of a set of edges s
is n minus number of connected
components of s so you know two vertices
are connected they're in the same Edge
or you know there's a bunch of edges you
can hop
across you can imagine taking a
hyperedge and replacing all the regular
undirected edges looking at those con
reg so um the span of some set of hyper
edges is again uh the set of hyper edges
where all the end points are already
connected by
your and uh and in the quote
quent then will be the edges that are
cut going across connected
components um and again actually the
rank is n minus one if G is
connected okay so um right so here then
a quotient might look like this so if
purple is is s then the remaining
colored edges are going across the
components induced by purple there's one
kind of interesting thing is that the
quotient is directly mapped to K Cuts I
break the graph into K
components and I look at the hyper edges
going across it okay but what's kind of
um uh
odd so K cuts of course include two cuts
where I just split the graph in half but
but unlike graphs you know in a graph um
if you preserve all the two cuts then
the k cut is going to be like the sum of
all the two cuts divided by two because
you're just double counting edges so if
you preserve two cuts you to preserve K
Cuts but that's not true for hypergraphs
an edge can appear in three or four or
five components so so so um that's sort
of something unusual about
hypergraphs and um right so so right so
some mod um quo specification I'm using
hypergraphs as an example I again want
to just decrease the number of elements
and and preserve the weight of all the
quotients of this fixed submodular
function and uh letting R be this kind
of thing like a
rank uh we get that the support is R log
RN overson
s and then you're able to preserve all
the quotients up to
1 so
generalizing the previous
slide um right there's an
algorith so so let's look at hyper
graphs I guess the distinction I'm
making here is now we're going to try to
preserve all the K Cuts in addition to
the two cuts have a hyper graph I want
to get a smaller number of edges and
preserve the weight of every k
cut and plugging in those parameters
from before you'll get n log n over
Epsilon s hyper edges and preserve the
weight of every k cut in addition to the
two
cuts um I'm going to give a couple more
examples just for because uh you know
what else could be modeled by some
modular function or this
framewor so so let's look at actually
Vector
spaces okay
so um we have some Vector Space X this
is linear algebra terminology not the
Metro terminology although it will
coincide at some level but you have some
overall Vector Space X like RN or
something and you have some Subspace Y
and then the kind of complimentary
Subspace or x sub minus y is called the
the quotient
space so okay here's uh then what we're
going to get uh let's say you have n
vectors and you have some weights on the
vectors okay we can find a subset of
vectors where the number of vectors is
proportional to the dimension of X so if
x is D dimensional you'll get D log n
over Epsilon 2
vectors and you you'll preserve the
weight of every one of these quotient
spaces
does anyone want to guess why I
guess okay so so there's something
called the linear Metroid which actually
inspires a lot of the
terminology um but we take ground set
all the vectors and the independent sets
are in the linear algebraic sense the
independent sets are
vectors and the the Metroid quotients of
the linear Metroid are going to map to
the these quotients
so that that's fun um oh does that case
follow from anything before or is it new
like the linear case uh to my knowledge
it's new and and I even uh bounced it
off a rune to see if we could recover it
other ways and we weren't able to find
other ways to yeah thank you I was
couldn't tell I also never imagined this
until I mean you know in hindsight we're
like oh what's a Metroid and you know
looking around
okay
uh here's another uh example that's kind
of fun take
coverage okay so you have uh elements
and
sets Okay and uh the elements are
weighted and what I want to do is
subsample these elements and preserve
the weight of every Union of sets so
that I can just run coverage or
something on a smaller set of
stuff so okay the the theorem is that we
can take our elements and and get it
down to a number of elements
proportional to the number of
sets Okay so in some overdetermined case
you have way more points than
sets and you can preserve the weight of
every Union up to a one plus
Epsilon so it's a little notation heavy
but this is the weight of some Union of
sets and this is the reweighted union
intersected with our
subsample okay so this is uh yeah want
to do the thing like before but one
thing kind of fun is one way to see this
well one way is you can reduce the
hyperg grass but another way is you can
look at this hitting set function where
um uh for a set of points I look at the
the the family of sets that cover at
least one
point and out comes the
quotients I because I got it backwards I
originally thought oh you know coverage
is sub modular so it'll be a function of
the sets but actually it's the hitting
side of the
on okay uh so for a lack of time I'm I'm
going to skip kind of most of
the the technical Parts uh but I have
full slides with little
more um but but at a high level if I had
more time I would talk about precedence
from carer's algorithm so carer had
already you know looked for example in
in the first step he's he's showing how
to preserve the minimum cut
in the
ground and this is followed up by by
Bank JN Carter who who show how to
preserve all the cuts in a
graph but a third uh important precedent
also connected to
Carter um but here's sort of papers I
think many of us are familiar with in
graphs um I'll skip this skip this as
well
um oh no let
me h a third a third paper I want to
mention by Carter is he he started
started to do to metroids what he had
been doing to graphs so he had studied a
random contraction algorithm uh in
metroids where you take an element and
you kind of look in the remaining
quotient um and and in some ways sort of
uh did the analog of preserving the
minimum cut he's trying to preserve the
minimum quotient in a Metroid so so
going into this we sort of had this uh
you can preserve the minimum cut you can
preserve all cuts and you can preserve
the minimum quotient so just for lack of
time I just kind of labeled these and um
doesn't matter too much you know we put
some effort into kind of decomposing a
Metroid and and doing some things
inspired by Bank ja
carer um
uh uh but morally we're sort of
occupying this bottom right Square where
okay we can preserve all Cuts we can
preserve the minimum quotient now we're
trying to preserve all the
quotients um I should maybe say one word
about
optimization uh to this end I'll only
make a pointer to in order to try to do
things fast if you wanted to do
something in your in your time we found
this kind of General push Rel label
framework of Frank and michos to be very
useful that's all I want
um okay and then I'll I'll just conclude
then sort of more informal conclusion so
you know there's there's lots of
interest in kind of spectral or more
algebraic Notions of sparsifiers so can
you captured this
generality uh you know along those lines
and and and an important point is K Cuts
you know can you do K Cuts in a hyper
graph because we're kind of used to you
know uh if you're trying to model things
as a vector I put everything on one side
is negative one everything on the other
side is one right it's on a line or
something but with K it's not even clear
where to
start um you know okay there's some
general theorem some general
sparsification maybe there's some fun
opportunities out there uh surprising
things we can sparsify that think of
examples I gave was just like oh it's
sub modular and you know working through
them and learning stuff but maybe if we
keep this in a back of mind we'll find
something
new uh I didn't talk about this too much
but in order to do things fast in graphs
and hypergraphs we we um did certain
decompositions of the graph and
hypergraph very fast it's roughly along
the tut Nash Williams kind of tree
packing and doing it recursively very
fast and uh you know just wondering oh
could this be useful for some other
context besides it's it's used to sort
of figure out the right sampling
probabilities when you decompose the
graph but maybe there's other other situ
thank
[Applause]
you I think the hypergraph like sry is
not a major and I noticed you use the
term polymor can you like explain it a
little bit Yeah Yeah there there do do
exist other ways like uh um L is
associated with a different Metroid
point of
view
um I'm sorry take a while but um so so
in short uh the rank function of a gra
of a graph is is just okay it's a rank
function for hyper graphs so so here you
know n minus number of connected
components uh start with an empty graph
right uh and I have a hyper edge with 10
vertices so immediately this goes down
by 10 you know it's not going down by
one like you would want for a ring
function but you still have monotone and
you have some
modularity um so I guess maybe this was
part of the motivation for the
generalization um uh maybe the best
example I have of why moving to greater
generality Is is useful but what's
important is that you know uh as you as
you add hyper edges to your your graph
and you connect more things each other
hyper Edge is connecting less right
because some of its end points are
already connected so as long as that
that
marginal contribution is going
down you'll be
okay not sure if this answers your
question very
well yeah
it's is the log and loss necessary in
some of
these is a log yeah okay the question is
is a log n loss
necessary
in some of
these well um I'll say Okay so the
question is is log n
necessary a log R log
n so something like this so um uh uh I
guess I I don't 100% know in the sense
that we do for spectral have these
stronger bounds that said
um within at least this line of argument
removing the log might also roughly
imply improving a login from like the
bank Che harder approach which I'm sure
we've all kind of tried once
before um and uh and when we're counting
quotients there's some end to the
something because you know the more
elements you have the more quotients you
can have so um those are just two
technical obstacles that's not as
necessary those are
things
any
[Applause]
question